From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Today is Thursday, June 9, 2011. My name is Joe Mosnier at the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill.
I'm with videographer John Bishop. We are in the Orangeburg South Carolina to complete an oral history interview
for the Civil Rights History Project, which is a joint undertaking of the Smithsonian's National Museum of African American History and Culture and the Library of Congress.
And we're delighted today to be with you, Mr. Cecil J. Williams. It's an honor and a privilege. Thank you for sitting down with us and welcoming us to your home and studio for this opportunity.
It's my great pleasure as well.
I'm just very much looking forward to the session today. So let me start our conversation with... can you just give a basic description of your childhood and youth and family and early education?
Well, I am the third sibling of Ethel and Cecil J. Williams. My father, who has, of course, and mother had passed away, but he was a self-employed tailor, worked in the city of Orangeburg.
My mother, all of her life, was an educator. She worked on a college level as well as a high school and a elementary level.
And I grew up in Orangeburg. This has been my home, my life's home. And I have preferred to remain here in spite of all the negative things and the...
in spite of the fact that this has been really the beginning and still is somewhat of a battleground for my race and trying to overcome all the barriers that arrive out of...
just trying to make a living and growing up in a... the segregation that I did grew up in under Jim Crow laws that affected the state of South Carolina.
But my mother taught me at a very early age that really that mostly people are like. We're more like than we are different.
And I grew up understanding. And I tried to treat all people of all races, all of my life as she did as fair as I could.
And I think that her lessons and my father's lessons, I think have helped to make me the person that I am today.
But I become aware I was going on relative to race and civil rights probably around seven or eight or nine years old.
As a youth, I remembered boarding. At that time we had a bus system here in Orangeburg, bus transportation system.
And I remember boarding the bus and my awareness of segregation probably came about as she told me that we had to sit in a certain section of the bus.
So we would usually... sometimes it changed. Sometimes it was that we were sit at the back of the bus and sometimes it was that we would have to sit maybe a certain section in the bus.
And it very definitely had a line that bought where we were to sit. It was either within that line and if the bus was crowded and where we were to sit was crowded, then we had to stand or not board the bus at all.
And so this was probably my very first lesson or experience in race and where we were to... we had a place.
So largely I grew up thinking that really Orangeburg, the citizens here, the white citizens, the black citizens, we lived in very parallel societies, a white society, a black society.
And there were separate playgrounds, separate schools. If we went to a movie theater, there was a place designated for African Americans. We either sat upstairs or downstairs. And it changed.
If we were to go into a store in downtown Orangeburg, we could go into the main store but if there's a lunch counter, we could not sit down at the lunch counter.
Of course I'm speaking about the period as I became an adult and as I became co-owns of my surroundings, the fifties, of course the early sixties.
If we were to say take a bus from the Orangeburg Greyhound Trailway Station, of course we would then also have to sit on that particular bus.
And so interstate transportation was also segregated. We had a certain place that we could... we would have to sit.
The school system that I grew up under from all the days that I was in education was also segregated. I went to the segregated elementary schools, segregated middle schools, segregated high school. My high school was Wilkinson High School.
So this kind of gives you an overview of my growing up in and around Orangeburg. And my family lived on Quick Street. I grew up on an area of Orangeburg that would be about two blocks from South Carolina State College.
And it was in the shadows of those colleges that my entire world, whatever experiences I had, were greatly influenced by the colleges.
And I would say that Orangeburg would be much less a significant place as it turned out to be, had it not been for the influence of those colleges, Claflin and South Carolina State College.
South Carolina South Carolina State College and Claflin University helped to really feel my experiences of life from the standpoint that they brought in cultural programs and speakers from the outside world, some internationally known.
And they feel that helped to round out my experiences from not living in a city of significant size.
Orangeburg, a largely agricultural community, we are about midways between Columbia, South Carolina and Charleston, South Carolina, Columbia being the capital, and Charleston being also a very significant area in a large population as well.
Well, see, approximately a percentage of the local population in the city in the town back in the 50s, black and white.
Roughly about 40% of African American, yes.
And you mentioned the two colleges and how significant those were to as institutions in the black community and in the city's life, in the towns life and in those days and now.
Where was your father's tailor shop and how did it relate to was there any tech black business community in the South of Detroit?
No, a business like tailoring and certain other businesses somehow enjoyed a very unique position.
For example, my father's business was almost entirely 80% clientele clientele were white and he worked for the, he did the alterations for the downtown stores.
Belk-Hudson (likely), as it was called, that doing those days, Bar Shays, Limehouse, Men's Stores.
And I worked doing the summer months and then sometimes on weekends I worked for my father.
I didn't ever learn how to, they do any tailoring, but I did deliver the clothes back to the stores after he finished the alterations.
And then I would take, at the end of the week, take the bills and go to the stores and collect the money.
And then my father would give me my little weekly allowance that way as well.
You got a camera when you were still, I don't even think 10 years old and that would obviously in some ways set you on the course that they came to your life's work.
So maybe you could recall the color of your first camera and how you moved forward from that.
Yes, my first camera which was given to me by, I think my brother, my brother had inherited the camera, I think my mother had purchased the camera.
A Kodak baby brown, which I still have and by the way, which still works.
But it was, as my brother's interest grew to music and blowing a saxophone, he gave me the camera and of course I started taking pictures.
And I was fascinated by the fact that you could capture an image and then see it.
And it was much later in my life that I discovered of course how to set up a dark room and develop in my own pictures.
But as I took pictures from people on Sundays, I would have them develop.
And this also became my hustle because I could earn a dollar or two on Sundays of people dressed up in their finalies.
And it is still gardens which is a local garden where we have a coarse water running, the it is still river runs through it.
And we have many rows and other varieties of things growing and it becomes a very popular place for both black and white citizens of course to go there and walk around the gardens and take pictures and lay on the grass.
And this one was a very unpopular place. And incidentally it was open to people who were all races at the time as well.
There was one of the places. So it had very unusual kinds of barriers.
Again a place like that was open but curiously a driving theater was close to blacks.
So since we would arrive in your own automobile but blacks could not go to drive ins.
But yet we could go to the stationary establishment but we would just sit upstairs or downstairs as it was sometimes.
The Edisto Theater and there was also a black movie theater at the time which was right across the street from South Carolina State and Claflin University.
And on Saturdays as a youth with my box of popcorn I would sit in there and watch the great movies of those days.
And the series of movies that came out like Captain Midnight, Captain Marvel, and The Phantom and Roy Rogers, Dale Evans, and Gene Autry.
And the series would be that the main character would get into some kind of trouble and almost reach the end of his.
He would have some perilous situation in which it would occur. But you'd have to come back next week to see what ultimately outcome.
And so I grew up with that kind of background. Of course it was a culture that was developing right underneath my very eyes of being a soci...
being receiving experiences from of course of motion pictures. Motion pictures were a very important part of my development as a person because it would be a aspiring photographer, the imagery of how that was done.
And the process itself I remember seeing at a very early age Gone with the Wind which at that time was a great accomplishment in a cinema production.
And MGM producing this very long motion picture that really depicted the old South. The fact of the changes coming as noted by the name Gone with the Wind.
Would you say that your household was a race conscious household with civil rights or race issues things that you talked about around the dinner table?
Or was it obviously it was something that was active and alive in the community? Was it at your dinner table?
Yes, but we did not encounter these barriers until of course we left our... what I thought was a very comfortable household.
And I don't think I could ever say that there was one day when even though my family was low income I don't think there was ever one day that we didn't have to eat what we wanted to eat.
So my I have a very caring parents and grandparents as it turned out as sometimes my mother and father were leaving the custody of my grandmother who was of course again very wise.
She had the wisdom of course years of living under her entire life she grew up under segregation.
But from my mother's side we grew up also with another kind of denominator that was kind of puzzling because we were a mixed race in my father's side Indian and black in my mother's side black and white.
So this was kind of puzzling because my mother was of a skin color that if you saw her you would not know what race she was.
And my father of course with coming with an Indian background Indian and black so it was very confusing to a youth of eight or nine years old as to where to fit.
And how to fit into this very mixed bag of racial placement that we had to adhere to or abide by or the other thing that was puzzling was that the fact that I grew up at a time when all this was state sanctioned segregation.
Legal segregation so a little difference between I think that kind of segregation and maybe a second in some other type of segregation but legal segregation where the state and I guess the nation the county the county puts up signs in the courthouse that says white water fountain colored water fountain.
The state which runs the schools in the city which runs the schools as you can't go to this particular school if you are colored so the places where we were able to go to school or shot take a bus we had federal state city and county regulation of these laws that effective.
Yes that effective me as African American growing up doing the time yes when did you first connect your camera.
Well probably around 12 or 13 years old maybe even I was born in 1937 yes maybe even earlier but looking back and when I was gathering information for the books that I have published this was something that I also was kind of trying to connect and get all the dates right but of course my
a lot of my photographs begin of course in my own household and a family and it's a rounding area but probably around 11 or 12 years old I have a mentor E.C. Jones from Sumter South Carolina and he was called into take photographs of the churches of Clarence and County where the Briggs and DeLaine and Pearson
families are beginning of battle that becomes really the catalyst of the Briggs versus Elliot petition and Jones found out that I was a photographer and that I had a camera and of course he would sometimes pick me up from Sumter and take me into those church meetings on Sunday and there we began taking what we were doing.
So that became the photographs that appear in many books today of the Briggs petitioners the Rev. J.A. DeLaine and I grew up you know seeing this happening but not totally understanding what was going on.
Yes and a lot of times Jones's studio by the name was Majestic Studio and sometimes in the pictures that I might have taken sometimes the ones that he took you might see his camera which had on again Majestic Studio.
Sumter was a very important city at that time because we had the the Air Force base there and Jones would purchase the out of date film supplies and paper supplies and then he would give that to me and as I began to develop my dog get my dog one going he would also sometimes kind of compensate me for my time and as he became the official photographer South Carolina State College he pulled me into of course taking pictures for state
because if I could take pictures at state college that would save him 80 mile round trip coming from Sumter but as the NAACP and Rev. Joseph A. DeLaine called him into action of course and then of course I accompanied him and that's how many of the photographs that we come up with relatives to Briggs v. Elliott.
That case those are how they were those came about.
Two questions one quick aside how did you first become connected to E.C. Jones.
Well E.C. Jones was a very close friend of my at one time my high school principal and one time my high school teacher Mr. Robert Howard they were of course at one time students at South Carolina State College.
So Mr. Howard recommended to Jones that of course he knew I had a camera and my better cameras by the way were also the cameras that I used at the high school board.
For example I remember using the course I was fascinated by film and of course they had the 60 in the middle of the bell and how camera and the four by five crown and speed graphic and the two and a quarter by three and a quarter speed and crown graphic cameras among the cameras that high school allowed me to well not not only high school but actually when I was in 10th 19th grade I was able to use the camera.
I was able to use those very expensive cameras at the time more so than the cameras that I had I grew up at say at taking photographs with the first camera of course was the baby brownie but it had no flash unit so I could not take a picture of anything that required a flash unit but I think I took my first pictures with a flash unit flash bulb of course I have a picture of third good Marshall coming off the train.
Well that was one of the first pictures but it was like but see a flash bulb at the time keep it by a camera or maybe $15 at the time from Sears Roebuck but the flash part of it the flash bulb was sort of out of sync because of a flash bulb in comparison to what you could buy a camera for was very expensive and it only flash one time.
And it was going and so typically we would I would go and maybe at 13 years old as I did take pictures of waiting and I'm putting 12 pictures in the brides waiting album and I only took 15 pictures of the whole waiting.
So because they were taking with the flash that was a very expensive part of it but the photograph of third good Marshall coming off the train and happened because the gentleman by the name who was the president of NAACP took me to Charleston because in my mind he had described this big lawyer that was coming down from New York and they had this big trial going on in Charleston South Carolina.
And that's when I took third good Marshall and one of his trips to the south where he got off the civil media and I snapped this picture of him on the civil media.
The president of the state and the ACP then was?
Well the president of the Orangeburg branch at the time was a gentleman by the name of Squire Morgan.
And the state at that time I don't know I only became aware of the state presidents of the NAACP at a later.
Revenue man.
Revenue man of course was also a good friend of Robert Howard and of course he would sometimes come and get me out of school.
And so a lot of times my field trips have become really was an exercise in the what was turning out to be the civil rights movement.
Sounds fair to say and you can tell me if I'm right that these gentlemen who were at that forefront at front edge of trying to advance the movement recognize even then photographs of this activity can be very helpful.
Yes.
And we need to be careful about this and think carefully.
Yes. Also the photographs were necessary because of this.
The local newspaper very rarely had news of interest to African Americans at the time to colored people.
In fact once in a while there was a section in the paper called news of interest to colored people that would appear once a week and it would just be a little bit.
But of course any action to demonstrate or protest would never be in there.
So it was because of that void that I began taking pictures for the news agencies that reach beyond Orangeburg.
So I started taking pictures for the Afro-American, the Pittsburgh Courier and of course ultimately a 15 years old I become an official correspondent for Jet Magazine.
Jet comes into Orangeburg from Chicago.
The story is developing and ongoing and they need somebody to continuously cover it.
And at 15 years old they made me a correspondent for a National Magazine.
And the money they pay to me at that time $35 for a photograph was a lot of money to a person in my age at that time.
I want to have you if you would and you were just an adolescent but take us back to one of those meetings in Clare Midd County and describe the people and the atmosphere and the mood and...
Well it takes place in many different time periods.
Number one most of the early people involved in the Clarendon County, South Carolina and the Briggs case.
Many of them were run away. They lost their jobs and were forced to leave.
So a lot of the pictures that E.C. Jones and I took were pictures of celebrations and pictures when they gathered together again at the churches for a commemoration or an awards ceremony.
And we came to photograph those ceremonies and those award presentations and gathering of...
And then sometimes at the request of the newspapers when they were asked together together, of course the entire Briggs petitioners get together at St. Mark and those photographs took place.
It's also interesting at this time from the standpoint of most historians is that Clarendon County, South Carolina and Orangeburg begin at such an early part of this and really they are the ones that are creating the catalysts from which the base of all the civil rights movement begins.
But at this time it's not even known as the civil rights movement. It's so early on into this new found way of saying trying to bring down these barriers that it doesn't seem to become known as the civil rights movement until really about 1955 when Martin Luther King and Rosa Parks with Montgomery Busboy Cut.
But the Briggs petitioners beginning 10 and 15 years earlier and the Brown versus Board of Education case, the catalysts, the template, the case that really started the Thurgood Marshall and the entire legal arm of the NAWACP,
the NAACP all in this direction was created by the Briggs case in Clarendon County, South Carolina starting off in the beginning as a bus transportation effort to get a bus for the children and then later developing in the case went to Charleston, wearing then Thurgood Marshall suddenly becomes aware that this might be it rather than having to go the way the NAWACP was going and having to maybe sue every school.
So, if you sue every school district in the entire United States in order to achieve equality and education, it was a case that maybe that might be the template for what they were looking for.
Do you remember when Brown came down in May of 54 you were in high school?
When Brown?
When the Brown decision came down in May of 1950.
Oh yes, I was, yes, yes.
What are your memories of that, of that, of that, of that ripple through the community?
Again, because of the dangers associated with this in the early stages and again the Briggs people you see were forced to leave and the delaying people were forced to remand delaying,
who by the way, my mother taught under the remand delaying and that's also how I have a close association with the lanes because my mother was a school teacher under him.
You have this danger aspect of the, that's not often written about, that's associated with it, that you don't really just talk about this because anyone talking about this might find themselves visited by the cookout client or you might find yourself if you're working for,
see the employment situation was mostly in control of whites and almost everything, any type of employment was really at the mercy of the white leaders.
And if you, in any way, were found to be associated with this effort to overthrow their way of life, your livelihood or sometimes your life was also in danger.
So I remember to answer specifically your question about what did I think after the Briggs Brown versus Board of Education case occurred.
It was one that was sometimes, you know, in very low tones discussed and you only discussed it maybe within the black society that you, and other people that were, that you knew.
But just generally out there, and now if you're going back to 1956, this was something that was not the celebration that you might think that it would be, that it was the pivotal case that brought this all to a turning point.
Yes, fascinating because you already knew from that direct personal experience with these families that the consequences could be so charged with violence, so charged with this, with the ultimate, all these ultimate consequences.
And in the small parts of Orangeburg County and Elloree School teachers and other little cities and camera, you see here you had an extreme form of racism that was also violence attached to it.
So there are many kinds of stories that have never been reported about people who just disappeared.
I think that kind of violence, that extra-judicial racial violence, the clan, others formally or informally organized.
Had that impinged on your immediate family directly or near extended family and your childhood years?
No, my mother and father warned me about it. Some white businessmen went to my father and told him that they advised him to advise me that I better be careful because they began to note that my pictures were appearing in the magazines and newspapers and outside agitators were using me to report on what was going on here.
And so probably three times maybe they went to him. And my mother was sort of isolated from it in that she was a part of the school system and knowing what happened to Reverend Rev. Joseph A. DeLaine, she often talked to me in a kind of a harsh way because, you see, again, people of my mother and fathers era, and the time they grew up in, they learned to deal with segregation and what was happening all around them.
And they formed sort of an accommodation type of relationship in a way to get along and also to put bread on the table.
If they were actually going out alone, they would be again subject to all kinds of situations which would have interrupted their lives.
The unity that they later become a part of in the demonstrations that developed in the late 50s and after in the early 60s, of course, then together they were able to then participate and then join forces.
And they lose any individual isolated attempts to antagonize them or fire them or what have you.
But when it was in the early years, it was very dangerous to, it was again, here are people coming together and we're talking about trying to change the state and federal,
and we're talking about constitutional change and things that would affect that and overthrowing state government.
And this is, more or less, looked upon as being anti-government or anti-treason or something.
You see, we were, it could be met with all kinds of ways and then a legality attached to it as well by the governing sources.
Did your parents ever find it necessary to ask you to stop doing this work?
No, in fact, my parents, I'm supported by my efforts. They saw the advances and they purchased me the cameras.
I remember doing a very severe thunderstorm and doing those days, of course, you were taught to, and maybe even now, taught to kind of remain quiet doing a very heavy downpour in thunderstorm.
I remember this particular time that as the storm was developing, I lay down on the floor and my mother lay it on the top of the bed.
And as we were waiting for the storm to pass and we could cut off all the lights and my father is on a chair also and everybody's remaining quiet.
And I remember this was my way. I had a captive audience there to sort of beg my mother for that camera that I had seen in the Sears Roebuck catalog.
And so that's when I took the advantage of it and they ordered me a brownie hawk eye, I think, camera.
And this was the camera, of course, with the flash unit attached with it. And at that time, I think $75 from Sears Roebuck.
And this was the way that you got something because the stores in Orangeburg or Columbia, Charleston probably would not carry that.
There were no camera stores as I remember even in the largest cities like Columbia, Charleston. So you would order things like this.
The Margaret was not nearly as popular. Maybe there might have been in African-American society, maybe one out of 10 families might have had a camera.
So me having a camera was very rare at the time.
Let me look, we talked a little bit about Clarendon County and how it set an early, early path towards Brown.
Orangeburg will be a place where immediately after Brown, you get an unusual movement, quickly emerged.
And just before we get to that, I want to ask one more thing. I knew in early 1955, the Clarenne is also active in the Brown and the climate created by Brown.
The political climate shifts on race, etc. becomes a very active consideration. You photographed the KKK rally.
Well, not exactly. I attended a KKK rally. Yes. It happened that I covered this particular stage of my life. I was a contributor to the Orangeburg Times in Democrat. I took pictures for them of Rex and I chased fires and things like that because they would pay me $5 for my photographs.
And of course, anything happened in Orangeburg. I felt myself to be somewhat of a correspondent for them.
And that was the standard everyday white newspaper.
That is correct. Yes. So I remember this particular incident where I went to a basketball game in Wilkinson High School and I took pictures for a yearbook in the newspaper, of course, which I was also the editor and that was also the photographer.
And the Clarenne rally, which was held on the Belleville Road, in a wooded area, was announced in the paper. And when I read it, without really thoroughly thinking a lot about it, I, and without asking my parents.
And of course, I must have been about 14 because I knew I had my drivers license and of course I could drive and this gave me access to moving around and taking pictures.
So I left the game and I said, well, I'll run by and see if that Clarenne rally, you know, not realizing that it was really held, not for blacks to attend, but really to intimidate people in the community, African-American community.
So when I got there, the Clarenne rally was already over. But there remained and outfronted, there were about two or three cars. And one of the cars was a highway patrol car.
And there was a truck, I think, and one of the cars, which I did not know about who belonged to. But what's standing there, at the end of the Clarenne rally, was this highway patrolman and the Grand Dragon, who had taken off his hood.
And they were, they're talking and also they were putting out the remains of the cross burning because it was all over and everybody had left.
So here I come, I parked my car on the Belleville Road and I walk up to them and they looked at each other and looked back at me and they said, well, what is this guy?
You know, does he not know any better? So I go up to them and I said, I said, looks like everything is over.
Something like that, I don't remember exactly what I said. But anyway, they were puzzled and confused in the fact that I'm here on this African-American, has come to take a picture of this.
What they, oh, I remember, as when I asked them and they said, yeah, it's already over. Then I turned around to leave. And I was leaving. They called me back and said, well, do you want to take a picture of us here? And I said, yeah.
So what happened? The cross, the burned out cross was then, it was laying on the ground. And then so the three of us re-irrected the cross and the hookuck clans dragged them and the high control and I re-irrected the cross.
And they stood in front of it and I took a picture of them. So when I told, later I told my mother, you know, what I had done, she said, you, you know, she really kind of was very angry.
And I was kind of, it was very angry because she realized that I had put myself in danger. But being so naive about, you know, the whole thing, it didn't occur to me.
And then, years later, they had put myself into the danger. And that's one of the pictures that, of course, I have lost. I cannot find my images of that today.
But I often think about the fact that, you know, these were very dangerous times.
On the other hand, there were a lot of instances where I, being an African-American of a lighter skin complexion, I find myself really baking, breaking barriers myself for my race.
Because at, I think, 18 years old, I, and then really accelerating my interest in photography, I want to become a member of the South Carolina professional photographers of America.
And there were no African-American members. And I read that they were meeting at Hilton Head South Carolina for a membership meeting.
So I called up the membership chairperson, Dan Bohrn of Walter Barra, and asked him about attending. He said, well, I don't know. He said, we don't have any, you know, colored photographers.
So he talked to someone, he called back, he said, sure, we'd be very happy to have you.
So I found myself in Hilton Head South Carolina. And there is a picture, of course, that I have where we all standing together as a group. And of course, I'm the only African-American.
And there were other incidents doing my life that I find myself kind of breaking barriers. And even though it's not open just because I try, just like when I tried to take the picture, and I tend to the Ku Klux Klan rally, that I find myself being accepted and led in or become a part of, leading up to doing my semester break when I was at Claflin University.
I remembered I visited my aunt and uncle doing the semester break and read a newspaper that senator John F. Kennedy was going to be at the Roosevelt Hotel and to make an announcement. At this time, Kennedy, there was speculation as to whether he would become a candidate, as there were others also contemplating on running for the presidency, but he had not announced yet.
This is about January 1960. And as it turned out, there I am in this room, in a ballroom, in downtown New York, and the security people noticed me. And at this time, you know, there are a few African-Americans in journalism, even with the New The New York Times, another very liberal newspaper at the time.
And they walk over to the hotel, walk over to the, to where I am, brother, in the ballroom, and they began to remove me from the room. And just at the moment, they were putting me out, John, send to Kennedy, and his wife were coming up to the podium, and they stopped them.
And he came over when we talked a few minutes, he gave me one of his cards, and he asked me about what, you know, where I was there and that kind of thing. And I told him that in my political science class at Claflin, we had discussed the fact that he might be a great president if he were to run, or he was to announce, if he was, was to announce.
And anyway, he, after we talked for a few minutes, and again, here's, here's this room full of press, and we're, here I am, they're talking with the person that would later become the president of the United States. And anyway, he asked, he, he cleared two seats, and told me to sit down here, and I sat down by Chet Huntley and David Brinkley, who won the front row.
And this gave me a great, I didn't have a telephoto lens, and of course, most of the still press photographers were regular, they were, they, then situated in the back of the room, and the TV people had, of course, the best view.
But all the still photographers were way back in the back. So this gave me very close, good close-up pictures of, then, Senator John F. Kennedy.
The significance of me being there though, I think was, it was the most opportune time because it was at this press conference that he announced that he would be a candidate. And so, I sent my pictures to him at Hyannis Port, Massachusetts, wherever he is on the campaign trail during the time on his road to the presidency.
I get an invitation to attend. When he lands in Columbia, South Carolina, I'm the only press person allowed to go in the the Caroline, which was his tenth seat of plane that he used to fly around in campaign.
And here I find myself, you know, in conversation, often with, again, a gentleman that becomes one of our greatest American presidents.
So there's, you know, unbelievable story come true that I had that kind of association with a person that, again, on the background that Johnson, of course, the enactment of the Civil Rights Act, or so forth, lead from that.
And but I was very much disturbed, of course, by his early death and all the things that happened as a result of that. But again, one of the most fascinating parts of my, you know, like growing up as a photographer, where there was events that surrounded that.
But let's pause just a second for Jonathan.
Okay, we're back on after after short break. Mr. Williams, let me ask you two, let's spend some time talking about the emergence of the movement after Brown and Orangeburg.
We've talked about the fact that there are two black colleges here, a very strong black community of substantial size, relative to the town population and such.
But Orangeburg will really be a place where you have a level and an intensity of early protest that as we were talking about what we started to be, this is often times lost from the narratives written by historians about these years.
And so let's spend some time really talking about that.
Orangeburg is vital and in my way, the second of four incidents in my opinion that really create a merciless civil rights movement.
And you see most of the people that were involved with the early Briggs case in Delayin and Pearson, they were run out of Clarendon County, South Carolina and they were not here.
But there's a gentleman by name of Billy DeLaine, and there were other leads over there that still remained and they were steadfast in resisting any, they were self-employed and they could exist, say without being ostracized or their loans coding and other things that the system used to fight against.
This integration attempt to do what they were doing.
So what happened, the movement then spreads to Orangeburg second most and that's why I think it is also a battleground again almost never mentioning any history books other than my own as being really one of the second battlegrounds or second of four events that lead to the creation of American's civil rights movement.
And what happened here again, the importance of it is that the closeness with the two communities, we are really 30 miles from Summerton, South Carolina and only 24 miles I think you have where the county line are.
So it also is important to the civil rights movement also, under school by the fact that where does Thurgood Marshall come to after the Brown versus Board of Education victory?
He comes back to Clarendon County, South Carolina and Orangeburg South Carolina and speaks at the gymnasium on Claflin University.
And he inspires then in about 1955 the community of Orangeburg to be one of the first in the nation to encourage their parents, the parents, to send their children in a test of the Supreme Court ruling.
So Orangeburg again becomes an early testing ground of the Brown versus Board of Education promise.
And so, can you tell me a little bit more about that that parents five Marshall as you recall?
Thurgood Marshall. Well, Thurgood Marshall, who I remember very vividly as being a very powerful in his mannerisms and his voice and he also used to curse quite a bit.
And you can imagine my joy in being able to associate because of the fact that I am the one hearing Orangeburg almost exclusively that I'm on the inside of the movement and most any other kind of press that would be associated with this because they would not be African American, they would be on the outside of the movement.
So here I am on have this very inside position as a photographer. But so when Thurgood Marshall comes back to Orangeburg of course I get in on the meetings and get to take a picture when they are talking.
He I remember him talking with the leaders of that time say James Sulton, Matthew McCollom and others and he speaks at again the Seabrook gymnasium and it becomes a rally and it comes up a time when funds are needed to try to support the ongoing effort.
And you also have on the stage sitting with him other national civil rights leaders who have also come back with him. And I remember riding in a car where Thurgood Marshall is in the front seat and I mean the back and there are two other persons and we go from visiting people that have again sacrificed a lot to the civil rights movement.
And also people that were willing to actually help financially who were able to financially assist with the movement. And then of course on the evening of the rally he makes this presentation before crowd around I think 1100 people the gymnasium is full, is packed.
And it's a time when I'm using a 4x5 crown graphic and also a I think I have a roller flex camera at the time as well. And my I'm taking photographs of this rally and I have probably in the entire series of photographs perhaps maybe a dozen pictures.
Unfortunately my negatives of beginning to deteriorate my 4x5 negatives of Thurgood Marshall have began to to kind of curl up and there it looks like a cancer is almost eating them and my 120 size negatives of beginning to fade away.
Fortunately, around 20 years ago I began well it might not have been that long because I remember it would have to be 17 years ago when I was working on Freedom & Justice.
And we were only in the early years of digital I scanned them in on floppy disks and now I have preserved those images and my images of of John F. Kennedy, Senator Kennedy also beginning to fade away and I've tried over years to maybe get some sort of grant because I have probably maybe a hundred thousand images that maybe only a very few of them.
So I do have been scanned and really they have appeared in the books that I have published. But Thurgood Marshall again was one of the most impressive people I've seen. And actually I did not associate him with being that person that maybe seven years earlier or four years earlier that I had photographed in Charles the South Carolina.
Because again in a mind of 11 year old you photographing someone and I only have a chance to take one picture and I seem coming off the train and then I think I'm not sure whether we stayed in Charles the night or whether we came back but I remember that we could not get into courthouse doing the briggs hearings in Charles the South Carolina.
But getting back to Thurgood again he was just an amazing person and the opportunity that I had in being with him and the opportunities I had of photographing again a person that comes to the United States president.
And so it was almost as if it had a divine purpose in mind that I'd be present to get those kind of events that really become the almost South Carolina's exclusive heritage and give some credibility to a lot of the individuals that came out of that.
In fact that this really happened. For example I have pictures almost exclusively of a group of people that paid quite a price, the Ellory School teachers and in no other publication other than mine has what they did been reported.
And now other history books are beginning to pick up on this so again I felt that it was my defining moment as a photographer maybe to be present to really capture these events and then now have them solve that history can be faithfully recorded and they be utilized as we go forward.
I really believe that the civil rights movement and the revolution that we engaged in and participated and marched and demonstrated I think it will have a greater importance 50 to 75 to 100 years from now than it does now.
We will have lived through it and the historians I think of tomorrow will see a more that it was a more important it was a very it was one of the most important times of history because the fact that you have America in this very
I guess in a way I can describe it as between a rock and a hard place here America is with the emerging democracy that they're trying to position themselves worldwide and other countries noting that they are not treating African Americans fair.
And the civil rights movement helped to establish America as a country of integrity country where morality and the Freedom & Justice and the quality of all citizens I think this came out of the civil rights movement and America I think is a better country today for everyone because of the civil rights movement.
And so I think that future historians will connect this a little better than the present historians have.
You said a very indescribable rally in the gym on Claflin's campus in 55 with 30 Marshall you reminded me of something that I think would be very interesting to have you talk about.
You graduate high school in 56 yes and I'd like to talk about the following a little bit because I think it says a lot about the realities that prevailed at the time you're offered present turner I believe yes state yes offers you a scholarship yes that will be rescinded yes later get it offer sort of a parallel offer to match that in a way yes from Clapton yes
and the one is a state back institution that draws on its fun to put the state yes as it's roots in the methods church yes can you tell you by telling that story can you illuminate the different pressures and tensions say on present turner and on the leadership of the class one and why how those how those realities shape that kind of story yes we're first of all my photographs of the period in jet magazine of a student rising in late 1955
the students had come you might say to the assistance of Orangeburg citizens who were involved in trying to overcome the head their parents had sent their children to had asked to petition school district five to send their children to school
this is this is crucial okay and and yes yes and again the path from that was again Thurgood's Marsha's visit and then the parents are encouraged and they petition to to integrate the school
yes yes yes so what happens again as state and Claflin students are urged to get involved we have a student leader by the name of Fred H. Moore the student government association and he is ultimately expelled for leading the students who are supporting the citizens of Orangeburg in a boycott you know counter boycott and of course at the time this is you know
you know a lot of papers national news in New The New York Times carers stories and this is on the jet magazine the opening story and so forth and the yes yes can you tell that in a little bit more detail okay the boy the activity by whites to pressure these black petition signers yes
yes as the parents who signed the petition to send their kids to school they their names are noted in the local newspaper and then some receive threats intimidation some people have loans calling and then there are others that and the list dwindles down from around 20 down to around 9 I think it
I think it it ought to be and what happens whatever way the people the whites in Orangeburg a white group forms called the citizens council and they seem to be the source of the of the pressure and any one supporting the cause to the parents sending this kids to school of course is also subject
to some kind of pressure so black citizens bound together and they form a counter boycott and they come up with a selective list of selected merchants that were they were not support who are who are members of the Citizens' Council and one in particular is the owner of the cocoa calling plan another is the owner of the exon distributing at that time is called the
at that time is called yes so yes so gasoline and the two the person's owning those companies again their businesses are then boycotted and merchants downtown who are known to support the Citizens' Council they are boycotted by Orangeburg citizens and as it was it was this boycotted effort that South Carolina state and
the class of students join to support and then Fred H. Moore being the student government association leader he is expelled by B.C. Turner Turner is a person that really as he's between a rock on a hard place I think I describe his position being that again here he is employed by the state of South Carolina and in effect
the the the board of trustees at this time is an all white trusty board and Moore is expelled and as a result of my photographs of Moore and the student demonstrations appearing and also photographs appearing in jet that embarrassed Turner the as I was graduate in college I had
a fully paid scholarship to attend South Carolina state college and Turner then because of my photographs appearing in jet then rescinds on the scholarship through a gentleman by the name of Mr. Harold Crawford he instructs him to tell me that my scholarship is rescinded and that I would not be welcome at state college
at the same time this is happening there's a new president occurring will be elected to clapping university Dr. H.V. Manning he learns about this incident and then gives me a scholarship in fact the exact same conditions and benefits that Turner had offered me and and of course it was ideal and probably more ideal
I go to clap them because I wanted to be closest to my profession and art was close to photography so it was where I studied photography and then obtained my degree from
Claflin University in art let's talk a little bit more about the unfolding movement in Orangeburg after after Fred H. Moore's expulsion yes and it's next couple next several years because really the movement remains will remain active for years yes and especially in Orangeburg see Orangeburg again you have the unique thing about Orangeburg is you have in a very small town
two African American colleges one is the state supported South Carolina State University and the other clap and so you have this melting pot you might say and and students coming in from all over the state all over the nation
and it's something that you don't find in too many cities other than you know especially the size of Orangeburg so again it becomes very important
because again because of the conditions of the time here are African Americans at a period in history when they are trying to make the words of the Supreme Court ruling they're trying to make it live out what the Supreme Court has ruled and it's not you have southern resistance you have everything going very slow towards that goal
and the students unlike their parents are not going to they're going to want this to happen now and so they move into action you find the early involvement of student activism occurring and Orangeburg is at the epic center of all of this even before Greensboro
and again history has got it really out of whack in the importance because here you have from in the modern civil rights movement you have Orangeburg again appearing before Greensboro but Greensboro gets all the attention and Martin Luther King and Rosa Parks getting all the attention in Montgomery Alabama
and here is the big situation happening they created the platform from which Martin Luther King and Rosa Parks were even reacting from that is Brown versus Board of Education
so let me ask to clarify one thing just to make sure my understanding of the one thing about petition is clear as I read and in fact probably also drawing on your work
yes one of the concerns that prompted that quick and aggressive reaction from the Citizens Council in Orangeburg when the group of black parents petitioned the school board was this was very soon after Brown and a great fear that on the part of the white community
that oh my gosh we may have there may be no alternative legal result from a standing petition but the desegregation so they were trying to literally sort of erase all names have the petition become moot because everyone had withdrawn is that correct?
yes they were trying to put pressure on them for them to withdraw their names so there would be no existing petition at that time.
correct yes and my turns out that Arthur Rose my art teacher was one of the signers he was from Charleston South Carolina and often our art education classes would turn into discussion about the movement because he was so much involved and he was
willing to put his children and he put his name he's one of the signatures and again they're unforgettable a very creative person but yet he was you know he had a very fiery attitude he wanted it to happen and he was willing to give probably his life to make it happen yes.
you just mentioned Mr. Rose and earlier mentioned that this group of school teachers and can you tell that can you give that account what happened with the teachers and of course you would take your photograph.
yes after Brown the state of South Carolina is just in turmoil they're trying to find all kinds of ways to circumvent of this preemcoach ruling and you have some schools with this threat of opening their doors to African Americans.
they're even just closing the school down and Cameron South Carolina nine miles from here in fact the one school just closed up.
but you also have reaction from the all-white legislature in Columbia where they are trying to think of and pass all kinds of laws to again circumvent the preemcoach ruling and one of the
the legislative actions calls for any teacher to declare before they are re-employed for the upcoming school year to declare whether they are members of the NAACP and they they
the elementary school teachers in April of 1956 rather than sign of this document stating that they are not members they prefer to resign.
the school principal Mr. Davis knows of my involvement with Jet magazine feels this is a historical moment that these teachers teachers are taking this very serious
action they're giving up their jobs he calls me to photograph them the teachers after I arrived they all line up in front of the school and I take a picture in front of the other training school and they again the importance of their action is sort of underscored by the fact that at this time Jet magazine is about that bigger magazine
and the son of four being right in the middle and at this time this picture is across the two pages of the Jet magazine and it becomes the largest picture of a publishing jet magazine at the time and they are called by Jet magazine as quiet heroes because again they weren't involved in marching they just prefer to give up their jobs rather than tonight.
the NAACP was really being outlawed in as many kinds of ways they were thinking the state legislators and politicians were trying to come up with all kinds of methods to really say that the NAACP was communist inspired they were trying to make it very in any community especially Orangeburg,
membership in the NAACP was considered to be very risky because if you worked and again the employment is almost totally in the hands of white citizens if you were found to be an NAACP supporter you might be dismissed just for that and the problem too being that if whites who didn't want to do this were found not to do this then they would receive pressure from the Citizens' Council.
and other white citizens so it just ricocheted like that so they in effect almost had to do many things that didn't even want to do but the Elloree School teachers course their effort was in some way under well seemingly as soon as they resign the positions were filled by other African Americans who did not want to do this.
they did not have were not on the same persuasion and I felt I always felt very upset the fact that here are these teachers giving up their jobs and then the jobs being really filled very fast for persons that were not involved in the movement.
the teachers by the way many of them never were able to regain employment again in South Carolina at the time and they were ostracized for quite a few years to come.
there are probably less than three of them alive today and most of them in the Orange Bay area and at Klaven University a few years ago we reconvene the existing persons that signed and I think that they are again representative of the kind of heroism that came from some individuals to numerous denaming who were in the middle of the world.
and the ground roots level of the civil rights movement so many nameless people who did so many things that again will go unnoticed unless we record their actions and so I've tried to do this with my publications.
and all of your work is such a record of that history. let me ask about one more thing in the maybe we'll take a break and come back and do some of the events after 1960 but you graduated in 1960 and opened the photography studio.
yes. and you're quite a young man still obviously early 20s you're just married.
how did you and of course all of the civil rights context is all around you. how were you going to make a living in Orangeburg with a new photography studio. how did you measure your prospects and what was going to pay bills?
well at this time a black business because of the separation of the communities a lot of times you had support from black citizens and that was a unique aspect of it rather than white citizens.
and so I could expect support from black citizens very easily and state college and classroom of course were main contractors with me and they gave me work because I did their yearbooks and their newspapers and so forth.
and but also my clients came from the students who were at state they could just walk across the track but this at this advantage point though it gave me the unique opportunity whenever there was a demonstration or a march that I didn't even know about they would have to pass right in front of my business.
and all I had to do was just go outside and take a picture of them as they were getting ready to march and often that happened I didn't even know that was going to be a march and I'm going to see everyone march and I just go outside and I have a couple of pictures in my book of you know across the street from my studio where they are marching in front of my studio.
what was the street address of that studio? the name of my studio? well that was on Boulevard and they were they say Boulevard run rights run right in front of the college campuses.
you have college avenue being the street right in front of the campus and Boulevard being the street that my business was on.
and as well as other black businesses, barbershops and so forth and what have you.
so it was my front seat to history.
yes. about me take a short break.
we're back after a short break. which was I thought I thought we could now turn our attention say to 1960 and after Greensboro very shortly after Greensboro of course here in Orangeburg demonstrations will be renewed.
and that press and other places can you describe the emergence of that protest activity here and how you interacted with it both as a photographer at times as a participant.
I've noticed through that books of history have recorded incidents of the civil rights movement and they are like here and here in this incident here.
but Orangeburg involvement in the civil rights movement. seemingly it was like a continuous.
there was always something going on from say about 47. all we up through 1968.
there was always something going on. Orangeburg was always involved in protest demonstrations or some type of activity and you're continuous.
that was because I think of the steadfast attitude of citizens who again very close to the Clarendon County, South Carolina situation.
here was where this great movement had it had ridden, ridden from this particular area and they wanted to see it completed.
so in about 1960 we found the students at state and Clafer and still involved in one movement or another.
and everything connected the fact that here we are trying to implement and make to make the Supreme Court ruling really a reality.
so they would affect and be here on every level a reality that we could look forward to.
because of the unevenness throughout the nation of employment and opportunities and the way that African Americans retreated in court and in legal situations.
it was just something that needed to be done in this movement and a momentum that it was undergoing and a metamorphosis from just being things going on as usual.
it had to change something had to be done about the conditions.
again here you find a situation where the soldiers are returning from fighting America's wars, African American soldiers.
they go to the European theaters, go to Japan, Korea, Vietnam, and come back to the United States and then find themselves again treated as second class citizens.
again this is something that had to be changed.
James Sulton is a person that comes to mind here in Orangeburg as being an example of a leader who after returning from World War II really found himself really in the middle of the Orangeburg movement and the effort to get the children into the public school systems of Orangeburg.
he is at the forefront along with Matthew McCollom and others.
around 1960 you also had on the college level an incident or maybe not well an incident but actually Harvey Gantt of Charleston, South Carolina was granted to the legal system and through Matthew J. Perry Jr.
and Constance Baker Motley, he had achieved victory of being ordered by the District Court, I think of South Carolina, to be admitted to Clemson.
and it was my great opportunity to be able to cover this event exclusively for Jet Magazine.
I represent it not only Jet Magazine but since there would be a limited number of people even on the campus of Clemson that day I also represented the black press.
there were only three African Americans on the campus of Clemson University at the morning when Harvey Gantt became the first in modern history to go to Clemson University.
and I remember covering it with again some awareness that violence could happen at any time.
this is happening at a time when James (James) Meredith was injured while involved in an activity.
I think in another state and you have some other violent activities that are taking place.
Slay it in order to contain this particular incident though has ordered the school closed just for Harvey Gant's admittance and all of the faculty has been ordered to lead the campus, all the students and Harvey Gantt and a sea of reporters.
really are the only ones along with Strom Thurmond (likely) and police authorities as he has been admitted to Clemson University and Strom Thurmond (likely)'s effort to maintain the security of his entrance.
they wanted to be able to contain in view the fact that there had been violence in previous attempts to for African American to enter a university.
I think in your book you mentioned the reason there are just the three African Americans are that they you and I think two other members of the press because the University administration told the black employees of the campus not to come to the campus that day.
yes even the black employees of the dining room were ordered not to report to the campus.
I had been a part of a convoy I think of about three cars and one involving Matthew J. Perry Jr again Matthew J. Perry Jr and Constance Baker Motley had assisted Gantt in gaining entrance to the Clemson University.
I think I've been about a four year court battle. Actually Gantt was really achieving a dream that I had one time I wanted to do myself.
I at one time I wanted to be an architect. In fact my studio that we are in now and my house next door and one of the house I actually designed myself.
I always wanted to be in photography no matter what else I would have gone into a photographer would have been in my main state but at one time I wanted to be an automobile design and then one time an architect.
I should say for the record these homes and this building and your home next door quite extraordinary pieces of architecture.
I actually given this area where you don't have contemporary design being very popular.
You know the letter I think way back to Stanford?
Right. Requested in that at that time an African American wanted to study for some degree that was offered by one of the state's segregated colleges.
Perhaps it might be offered out of state tuition. So I wrote to at that time Governor Strom Thurmond and of course I never got a reply.
I followed the procedures but never got a reply so I was kind of ignored altogether. Maybe the funds weren't available or I didn't have any political cloud or whatever but I wasn't able to do that.
So the incident at state college in Klaaflan was what my fate was to be. But on Clemson that morning again things went along very quietly everything took place and again it became again the first of his race to go to Clemson.
Incidentally back in the doing reconstruction African Americans had attended the University of South Carolina.
But again in modern times again there were no African American students at any of the South Carolina's colleges.
So Gantt was really setting the pace for other things that would happen in the integration of Clemson University and also the integration of the University of South Carolina by African American students as well.
Let me ask you had to earlier mention this rather exceptional meeting with John Kennedy in 1960.
You've just mentioned the art against entrance to Clemson in 1963 and so you put me in mind of of of course Kennedy's assassination later in 1963 and I wonder I should ask kind of your reaction as you recall it to Kennedy's assassination.
Well African Americans as well I think is majority of people in that observed in this community black and white are really were very very upset.
I mean it was almost a bit some natural disaster had taken places I remember I mean people were crying everywhere it was a very emotional time.
I remember they were having a special ceremony at state college and where people just sat in silence for a few minutes.
So he was very but loved president and again doing his very short time in office had demonstrated willingness to try to change the image of this country and put on.
Putting place some of the laws we talked about and I by way was invited to the inauguration but was unable to go I think I would have enjoyed that but for many reasons I wasn't able to go but but he put into place many of the things again that under president Johnson allow the Civil Rights Act of the 19 early 19 the mid 1960s to take place and of course then we have.
Some of the great changes occurring in race relations in the United States doing that for your time and I think it came about because Kennedy said it in a motion.
Let me ask about let's talk a little about the way the ways in which Orangeburg did not did and did not change through these years and I thought we might start that conversation in 61 you took an extraordinary photograph of two young African Americans on the step of.
The way press security and church where I think they are met by the mayor of Orangeburg can you tell that story and what that represent yes to friends of mine Dorothy van and Emmanuel Hickson wanted to attend a church in downtown Orangeburg and I think for the experience and they were both from other states that they won being from Virginia and the other one being from.
I think New York or maybe another state so on this particular morning I got a tip from someone that they that these two students were going to go to the I think sent Paul church in downtown Orangeburg and I got in my car I went down there but I didn't know which church they were at so I really just circled the area and finally I saw the students about to go out the street.
About to go up the steps so I jumped out of my car left the door and I ran up the steps and they had already knocked on the door the doors closed and services had already begun and in a minute a person put their head out of the door it turned out to be a mere Clyde fair.
At the time he was a member of that church but he was a mayor of the city of Orangeburg and I photographed a picture of the two students being rejected and I also observed him when he said that this is a segregated church you can't come in go worship with your own people.
At this particular time in my life and this picture was also had a very powerful influence on my life as well at this particular time.
Similarly my relationship with the state newspaper and the Times Democrat isn't one where I can actually sell pictures to them so what happened I thought this picture would be of great importance and I drove to Columbia South Carolina after I developed the pictures.
At that time the Associated Press was located on the second floor of the state newspaper and I carried the picture into them and I think I sold it to them for $35.
The next day around the world the picture was on publications in Germany or many countries in many other countries throughout the United States and many newspapers including the front page.
I think that time the Washington Star which was the most prominent daily in Washington D.C., and I think in New The New York Times then it was in magazines and newspapers later on but on the day after again on the front page of papers around the world showing that this southern mayor refusing entrance to a church.
It turned out that this helped people to realize that one of the most segregated places in America at any given time was on a Sunday morning anywhere in the South that African Americans could not attend even a church of their choice and so we were still living in a very segregated society.
And what happened though after that picture appeared about a month by the way I had finished college at the time and I was continuing my studies I was working on my masses at South Carolina State College and I had still yet a deferment and the selective service called me in to for an interview.
And I knew that that picture had really provoked them go caught their attention because as I sat down in their office on Doyle Street here in Orangeburg for the interview one of the I think one of the ladies reached up in this vertical foul cabinet and as she reached up the pool the maneuver fold or containing my name and it opened accidentally the newspaper clipping.
Then kind of floated like a feather falling to the floor so and that was my picture they had clipped from one of the newspapers so I knew that it was probably associated with what they later did in telling me that I had 30 days of clean up my fair that they were going to draft me so I was I didn't want to be in the army I joined the Air Force but I had to close my studio.
I just kind of leave everything as it was and I felt again this was another way that they you might say finally got me because they had again worn my and this is the system you might say and some of the I'm talking about a general attitude but here here's one of the persons that's fanned in the fire as here's one of the ones that's publicizing these things that happened here's this person that's helping to wreck our way of life.
I was in the mind of many people including the people that made up the selective service board.
So you joined the Air Force? Yes. I was in Air Force I was in Air Force I was very short while while I was in Air Force I was injured doing flights doing my training and did not what I spent about a month and a half in a hospital and then I returned to Orangebury and then I had sold my studio before leaving going to the airport.
So I had to kind of reestablish my business and all over again and get reestablished. I was going to be training other photographers I had a very good situation when I joined the Air Force I was going to be training other photographers in Florida but I had to finish my training in San Antonio, Texas but it was not to be and so I was glad to get in but I was also glad to get out.
I'm happy for the historical record that you came back and kept photographing. Let me ask about a few more things and let's spend the last chunk of our time together talking about 68.
Along the way you will photograph student protests on the steps of the State Capitol in Columbia in 62. Again, you made a very good point a few moments ago and what I wanted to acknowledge that this is a story more of continuity, episodic outbreaks but we do tend to focus on moments rather than the continuum but these landmarks in the air.
The landmarks in the history here in South Carolina, the student protests in the State Capitol in 62, the desegregation of the University of South Carolina in 63. Very interesting challenge to racial segregation in the waiting rooms in Orangeburg but a local hospital here in Orangebury in 63 with Miss Blackwell, Rackley Blackwell.
And you're even approached by the White Citizens Council member to thank with an interesting offer along that span.
Yes. Let's talk about that and then we'll talk about 68.
Yes, I don't remember the exact year but I remember probably two times in my career being approached by persons associated with the Citizens' Council and again since the employment situation was almost entirely in hands of influential white citizens.
A Black person's fate was often determined by them and if you were known to be associated with the protest that was going on, you might be fired or something else might happen to you or you're alone, cold in all kinds of things to disrupt your life.
And so I took a picture of a meeting of Concerned Citizens at Trinity AME Church and it was a picture of showing the faces because I took it from the standpoint of the podium back on the...
And there must have been someone in the Black community who told someone in the Citizens' Council that I had such a picture or it was known that when there was a meeting Cecil Williams probably had those pictures, one or the other.
So this person that identified even up to today as Jack approached me and offered me, he just came up with all kinds of offers to see if I would sell those pictures to him and of course I never did.
I thought that this was an attempted bribe and I went back to Reverend Matthew McCollom and I told him that this is what had happened and I had refused and that picture would never get to them.
But mainly what they wanted to do was to take my picture and then see what faces they could identify, what members of the community could be identified that they would be able to put some kind of pressure.
And mainly they were interested in maybe even from the leadership standpoint who were the ones that were often in the paper you would have a report from the papers that saying that, well hey, I'm Black, so this is [a problem in] Orangeburg, it's not them that's doing this.
These outside agitators are communists and infiltrators that wanted that would not let situations lie as they were.
Although they may have been some of that still yet again, there was no communists and infiltrators when this whole thing started and it was an African American movement that black citizens started.
Let's tell me about the context for the Orangeburg Massacre in 68 at bowling alley in relation to the segregation of the attempted desegregation at bowling alley.
How much did Orangeburg change after 64 and 65, the Civil Rights Act in Voting Rights Act? How much did the community change?
During the period of, say, 62 to 68, many things had, you had a lot of tokenism, you had a lot of blacks being hired, various places, you had most places after 1963, 64 and 65, the Voting Rights Act and the other civil rights legislation taking place.
You had a lot of changes taking place and they were felt here in South Carolina and they were very much appreciated and they were enjoying the benefits of those changes.
But there were some pockets of resistance, some places, for example the churches still were largely segregated.
And then also you had some places like bowling alleys and restaurants that in South Carolina had still not welcomed African Americans to go into or to shop or whatever.
And one here in Orangeburg was the All-Star Bowling Alley. Any student leaving South Carolina State College and Claflin or any citizen walking uptown from the area of the campus and going up into the city of Orangeburg, if you were on Russell Street you would pass by a strip mall on the right-hand side and out front there was a sign that hung identifying this as the All-Star Bowling Alley but then it was a small sign that said white people were going to go to the city of Orangeburg.
So if you were walking uptown to spend your money to purchase something you would pass by that sound every day or if you were riding by you would see it. It was large enough. It's about maybe a seven inch by three inch sign that said white only.
And so this is one of the facilities that is not allowed African Americans. Some students at State College who have been driving to Columbia to Bowling and going other places because they were not welcome there decided that they would not take this anymore and they decided to go to the bowling alley and they were arrested.
And then hearing about the arrests there were others from the campus that also joined. I get involved on about February the 6th, where I hear that there's a commotion going on at the bowling alley and that the students from South Carolina State College and Claflin.
And being the yearbook photographer for South Carolina State College and Claflin, wherever the students were I was. I would catch all of their athletic activities, all of their student activities, all their leisure programs. And so here they were involved in a protest. So that's where I was.
And what happened the students and approximately 250 or 300 students are in the area of the strip mall and they you have approximately 50 or 75 highway patrolman city police and others that are there and they're trying to tell the students to leave the area, you know, go back to your campus or you will be arrested.
And just as all that was going on, I am a student pressed against a glass in one of the vacant stores in the mall and everyone's of course in a very packed or tight situation and the least movement caused the student to break this window.
And as you broke the window, everybody heard the commotion and police authorities started raising their clubs as if somebody had maybe intentionally done this and they began trying to hit people. And so everyone started running away including myself.
I had at that time a twin lens camera, you know, had it around my neck. And of course I started running too. In fact, I left my car because my car was parked out on Russell Street.
I left the area and I turned left towards the campus because that's where the greater number of students were headed. And just as I turned by a former furniture store known as Sutcliffe's furniture store, I looked back and I saw a female student fall to the ground.
And then I saw two city policemen start beating on her head with clubs just because of the fact that she had fallen, not because she had done anything and because she was running.
So that just shows you the cruelty and the brutality that police authorities were using say this was three days before the what turned out to be the Orangeburg Massacre.
On the night of the Orangeburg Massacre, I had returned from Columbia, South Carolina and of course I had been covering all the activities ongoing.
And I came to State College from the area from again on college Avenue and right in front of (right in) front of Claflin, I could not get any further because there were police authorities blocking there.
And I tried to circumvent where that blockage was and I went to another area but I couldn't get in there either. Then I had a couple of little other areas that I could that I knew that was on the campus itself from some other streets to get in but I could not get in.
So there was no I found no way to be able to get on to the campus of State College on that particular evening.
Later I would find out that might be unable to get there probably saved my life because doing the night, doing a time after the students had built a bonfire, nine highway patrolmen started creeping up on the campus of State College and they started firing their shotguns into a crowd of about 250 students.
And ultimately they after I think about nine or 10 seconds of firing, you have the three students who were later found to be killed.
Then you had about 27 injured and you have perhaps many, many more some of whom have never come forward that also receive a very minor injuries.
And almost all of the injuries are injuries from the back. Jack Bass has a great book out called The Orangeburg Massacre which tells the story in detail and he and Jack Nelson did a very good reportage on that.
My book called Orangeburg 1968 also has the visual coverage on the pictures from that particular date.
But the morning after the massacre I got in my car drove to the State College campus and there was an airy atmosphere surrounding the area where the students were the night before and where the killings had taken place.
It was an overcast morning, it was very cold, I had on my overcoat and this is about 6, 30, 7 o'clock in the morning.
And I noticed that the maintenance structure on the campus had arrived and they were picking up all of the debris to clean up the area.
And so I looked down and I saw shotgun shells and other debris spread all over the air where the students had been killed and I started picking those shells up and putting them in my pockets.
And then the maintenance truck would also was picking up other things at the same time.
Later, after my picture appears in I think Time and Newsweek and in newspapers all over the United States.
I should mention that I took a picture of the shells, I really stood it, I posed the picture of a student holding the shells.
And I think I had about 7 or 8 or 9 shells.
And later after this picture appeared in many publications, national publications around the United States.
The Federal Bureau of Investigation confiscated the shells from me and they later were used as a trial is developed to try to highway patrolmen.
And they laid the shells that I picked up to coming from 9 highway patrolmen who had actually fired or killed the students.
As it turned out in a trial in Florence, South Carolina, the 9 highway patrolmen were found not guilty.
And to bring that up to today, I think that only a couple of years the FBI considered maybe reinvestigating reopening this particular case but they failed to do so as well.
And it was also offered a job to be to join the FBI at that time.
At this time in 1968 there were very few African Americans and the FBI agent who got the shells from me informed me that J. Edgar.
who himself had asked him to ask me if I wanted to be an FBI agent.
And of course I refused that offer because I didn't know whether it was a genuine effort or whether they wanted really just to have an effort.
And it made me an informant out of me which I refused.
In more recent times we've heard a case where some photographers were approaching the same where I was.
Whenever I received a notice of that type, I usually would inform the local officers that this is taking place.
And as I did with that particular, again I told Robert Matthew McCollom and James Sulton that had been approached by the FBI and also Oscar Butler who was also seemingly of interest to them because again he was the student.
The university is over the student organizations on the campus and they felt that they...
We're seeking information on him as well.
And the FBI, again although investigating this particular case in my opinion failed to do the job that they should have done because there was no doubt who killed the students.
The fact is that there were no guns found to belong to any students.
And although an officer had been injured by a part of a railing from a house next door doing the time there were students there, still yet there was no massive effort.
And anything to justify the highway patrolman really firing upon the students.
And this incident came to be known as the Orangeburg Massacre because that's exactly what it was. They were defenseless.
They didn't have any weapons.
And to today it's also unfortunately one of the stories about things happening this era that many publications and people really don't know about.
It hadn't been reported in many publications other than my own.
I think there are two books about it or mine and the one by Jack Bass.
And it's nowhere nearly as well known as the Kent State Massacre where they were protesting also at the time again for the involvement of the United States in the...
I think the Vietnam War where students were also fired upon by highway patrolman and also national guardsmen.
I know that Justice Ernest A. Finney Jr and well not then Justice Ernest A. Finney Jr but he was then the head of the (SC) Human Affairs Commission.
Another member of both resigned in 1969 out of their frustration over the lack of prosecutorial effort in the wake of the massacre.
Yes.
John, let's pause here for a moment.
We're back after short break and we're going to finish today.
I've approached very appropriately I think with a look at some of your work Mr. Williams and just some reflections as you have several volumes with the picture published.
These are some pictures of...
I think that I probably have probably more inside details than I think of any other civil rights publication I know.
Again pictures coming from the inside of the movement but here are students getting out of jail.
These are the photographs that often you don't see into other publications because again you see the major event or incident but again these are the kind of behind the scenes.
Money was raised and being able to students out and here that you see them getting out of jail and some of the students have a jubilant look because...
although they on sacrifice themselves the go to jail they're also happy to get out because jail conditions were very terrible at this time.
One of the largest demonstrations in civil rights history and the largest number of arrests occurred at what is called the the the Pink Palace.
Is there a way to turn to that?
Turn to the the the Pink Palace.
Now I was a jail here at the city police. This is where I went to jail twice.
And of course usually the NAACP would bail me out and I was never even fully booked.
I would be bailed out first because they wanted me to continue taking the photographs.
But here are students in what is called the stockade of the the the Pink Palace.
And one of the photographs associated with this was on the front pages of the The New York Times and around the world where at one time the largest number of demonstrators ever arrested in a mass civil rights protest was this particular one.
388 I think were arrested.
So many were arrested that it overfilled even this facility and even penitentiary buses were called in from Columbia to haul the students back to the penitentiary.
So again this is about... I'm not sure what this is.
1960.
1960 correct, yes.
That was the first real large, direct action protest at Greensboro.
And I think what happened was if I remember what that photo shows is how demonstrators were funneled into a fence theory behind the jail.
Yes. It was a cold February morning. I remember that and the students were wet.
The water hoses were called in and they were wet and placed in these facilities.
The other unique thing about America's civil rights movement, especially the events happening in the South in the deep South in South Carolina and among the students that I have associated with was the fact that students were well dressed often when they participated in a movement.
The men would have on a shirt and tie and a coat and the young ladies were looking like they were going to church.
So they were well dressed and they were well orderly.
Then they were well behaved even before Martin Luther King's call for nonviolent passive resistance.
So this is an underscore of the fact that they wanted to peacefully achieve these objectives of equality and justice and freedom for all.
Is there any particular?
No, really. There are some other things that really come with all that to be.
This is a photograph that I have in my office. This is I think about 1963, Downtown Orangeburg and here you have 3000 people including my own mother who are part of a demonstration.
They have really come here to pray for peace and tranquility and also for opportunities.
And also asking I think one of the ministers who pray to ask that city authorities also employ black youth and employ black citizens.
You have this time where you have almost no black city police, no blacks in the city council, no blacks in the county government, nothing.
So it's still even in 1963 a very segregated area that we live in.
I tried to with with Out of the Box in Dixie produce a top quality book that would be representative of the dignity of the movement that occur.
And the fact that here is my effort to bring too light some of the unsung heroes who started and kept the civil rights movement objectives ongoing.
There is almost no picture of the people that most people associate with the civil rights movement Martin Luther King (Jr.), Rosa Parks, Jesse Jackson in my book.
Here are unknown unsung heroes who are really making the movement happen and moving along and at the grassroots level of the movement.
It starts with the beginning of the civil rights movement in Clarendon County, South Carolina and it goes through really the 2000 year 2008 or 2009 with my coverage of events that largely fall into the pursuit of African Americans trying to achieve.
They're full citizenship in America and so this is my contribution hopefully to that effort.
Let me know too for the record that there are two other books that you've published we mentioned one already Freedom & Justice and another.
And The Orangeburg Massacre again puts the faces to the movement and also it has the stories and interviews that persons injured.
You have here stories of the persons who were actually shot and the words of how it was when they realized that they were bleeding and the very graphic illustrations.
And again from the yearbook which I was a yearbook photographer time I tried to pull their picture of what were they involved in the time that this happened and to have some background to what went on.
This is John Stroman who was again they tried to make a scapegoat of him and it went on tried to charge him with disobedience and riot charges.
The only person jailed relative to The Orangeburg Massacre was Cleveland sellers.
Sellers was really jailed not for the events that happened in 1968 he was actually jailed for the incident that happened that I described earlier on February 6 where the police authorities are called into the bowling alley area.
Because he was not even at the actual site when it first went on he was I think of walking by. Sellers today has moved from that era to really today being the president of Voorhees College.
Mr Williams let me thank you so much for being so generous with your time and your work and all just extraordinary perspectives.
Thank you, it's a very good part of this.
Thank you for something.
You the one that is I'm sorry we still own camera.
We will just cut the one where we can stop there.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.